it's been six years since the financial
crisis and then a lot of people who
wonder why does no Bank been brought up
on any criminal charges well in daiting
a bank is a tricky thing if the
government was to label a major
financial institution of criminal
enterprise there could then be a run on
that back causing hard greater damage to
the economy then whatever malfeasance
was conducted by that hey so what's a
federal prosecutor to do so far
government lawyers have avoided this
doomsday scenario by brokering
settlements called deferred prosecution
agreements in 2012 the US Department of
Justice accused bank HSBC of stunning
failures related to money laundering but
instead of going to court HSBC admitted
to the violations and agreed to forfeit
1.3 billion dollars today to big banks
are under the federal microscope Swiss
banking giant Credit Suisse is facing
indictment over helping Americans evade
taxes france's largest bank BNP Paribas
has been investigated for processing
transactions from blacklisted companies
in countries like Sudan Cuba and Iran
there haven't been any criminal
indictments yet but that doesn't mean
there won't be to be clearly no
individual or company no matter how
large or how profitable is above the law
the prevailing argument particularly in
the financial community is that any
criminal prosecution could result in a
bank losing its charter which could then
set off a panic in the market and cause
general financial havoc the US Attorney
for the Southern District of New York
Preet Bharara thinks that argument is
just a scare tactic calling it a gaping
liability loophole that blameworthy
companies are only too willing to
exploit the question is whether it's
just that or if banks that are too big
to fail are in fact too big to jail
you